[Music]
on the morning of september 11 2001
tragedy struck when two hijacked
airplanes crashed into the world trade
center towers in new york city
after that
everything changed
for the past 20 years america has
grappled with the question of
could it happen again
where would the attack come from
what could we do to prepare
and
could we stop it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if 9 11 happened again
the attacks on the world trade center
took the lives of nearly 3 000 people
and consumed america with outrage fear
and grief
the thought of a large-scale attack on
americans in their own country was no
longer unthinkable
it was on everyone's mind
what if terrorists did strike again what
if this time they use biological weapons
or even nuclear weapons
which city would be the next target
would washington dc be next
needless to say the collective
consciousness had changed forever
20 years later we're still asking these
questions
with american troops pulled out of
afghanistan
tensions once again rise whether there
could be another attack on u.s soil
would america be prepared for another
attack
well here's the thing
this isn't the america you knew 20 years
ago
over the last two decades the united
states government has gotten a major
upgrade to its defensive and offensive
capabilities
the big one being its intelligence
community
let's break it down
between 2002 and 2017 the united states
spent an estimated 2.8 trillion on
counter-terrorism
so you've got the cia fbi and national
security agency right
all getting expanded
then you've got a newly formed
department of homeland security
plus the special forces are doubling
down on counter-terrorism capabilities
they've now got access to a whole new
densely tangled network of intelligence
collection technologies
this tech collects all types of signals
that can be used to target individuals
or groups who may be planning attacks
now more than ever it's harder for
terrorist groups such as al qaeda to
organize an attack similar to 911
with today's far more advanced
intelligence agencies on alert
a mass casualty attack is a lot less
likely to slip through the cracks
but
it's not impossible
even with all the preparation in the
world an attack on american soil could
always be a possibility
there are hundreds of places around the
globe that could house terrorists
organizing attacks on american targets
but it won't be another 911.
the events of september 11 2001 were a
heartbreaking tragedy and a defining
moment for americans
there was life before 9 11
and there was life after 9 11.
government travel
media society
everything changed
another attack in america
wouldn't be a repeat of 911
it would be something new entirely
but what if the next attack was bigger
than any of us expected
what if world war iii happened tomorrow
well
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]